R
COUNTRY IS.
JOINING US TO EXPAND ON THIS AND
SO MUCH MORE, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR, FORMER WHITE HOUSE
CHIEF OF STAFF KARL ROVE.
I THINK WE NEED TO RECALIBRATE
ONCE IN A WHILE.
DO YOU THINK SOMETIMES PEOPLE
FORGET HOWE GREAT THIS PLACE IS?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
AND THANKS FOR DOING THIS
SEGMENT.
IT WAS A PLEASANT SURPRISE.
AS A COUNTRY WE FOCUS ON THE BAD
THINGS, BUT WE DON'T UNDERSTAND
AND PUT THEM IN THE CONTEXT OF
WHAT THIS COUNTRY IS AND WHAT IT
REPRESENTS AROUND THE WORLD.
EVEN THE PROBLEMS WE HAVE ON THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
PEOPLE ARE COMING HERE NOT
BECAUSE THEY THINK IT'S A HELL
HOLE.
THEY ARE COMING HERE BECAUSE
THEY BELIEVE IN WHAT THEY HEARD
ABOUT THE AMERICAN DREAM.
THE ABILITY OF PEOPLE OF MOD
YECHTD BACKGROUNDS TO RAISE ON
HARD WORK AND COMMITMENT.
I WAS TALKING THIS MORNING WITH
THE AMBASSADOR OF THE UNITED
STATES TO THE COUNTRY OF
NETHERLANDS WHICH HAS THE SECOND
LARGEST U.S. MILITARY CEMETERY
ABROAD.
THE GRAVES THERE ARE TENDED BY
VOLUNTEERS, DUTCH VOLUNTEERS WHO
TEND THOSE GRAVES.
WHY DO THEY DO THAT?
BECAUSE THE UNITED STATES CAME
IN WORLD WAR II AND HELPED
LIBERATE THEIR COUNTRY, AND THE
ONLY THING WE ASKED FOR IN
RETURN WAS GROUND IN WHICH TO
PLACE OUR DEAD.
THAT'S THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
GOD BLESS THE FOUNDERS OF OUR
COUNTRY FOR SENDING US IN THE
DIRECTION THEY DID.
BRIAN: ABSOLUTELY.
LET'S TALK ABOUT WHAT'S
HAPPENING AT THE BORDER.
WE HAVE NEVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
THIS, KARL ROVE.
WE HAVE NEVER SEEN WHAT LOOKS TO
BE BASICALLY AN INVASION.
IN EL PASO ALONE THERE IS AN
INCREASE OF 250%.
WHEN TITLE 42 GOES AWAY ON THE
21st, WE ARE EXPECTING 18,000
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS A DAY.
WE DIDN'T HANDLE 5.
MR. IS PRESIDENT BIDEN ON THIS?
>> WE HAVE A BIG BORDER IN THE
SOUTH AND IT TAKES A LOT TO
PROTECT IT.
WE CALL THOSE ENCOUNTERS.
THAT'S WHEN THE CBP, THE BORDER
PATROL, TAKES INTO CUSTODY
SOMEONE ON THE BORDER.
2021 THERE WERE 1,734,000.
THE END OF THIS WE ARE.
2,378,000.
THAT'S OVER A 500 PERCENT
INCREASE IN THREE YEARS.
IN OCTOBER 230,000 ENCOUNTERED
ACROSS THE BORDER.
IN 2020 IT'S ESTIMATED THERE
WERE 600,000 GETAWAYS.
WE A YOU IN HE WILL PASS -- WE
SAW IN EL PASO.
1,000 PEOPLE FROM VENEZUELA AND
CENTRAL AND SOUTH AMERICA, CAME
ACROSS.
LITERALLY THERE WAS NO SPACE IN
THE SHELTERS.
THESE PEOPLE SPEND THE NIGHT ON
THE STREETS GRABBING WHATEVER
KINDS OF CARDBOARD OR MAYBE THEY
COULD TO START FIRES TO KEEP
THEMSELVES WARM.
WE SAW THAT.
THAT'S HAPPENING IN SMALLER
TOWNS ACROSS THE BORDER.
EAGLE PASS OR YUMA, ARIZONA.
WE ONLY GRAB IT BECAUSE IN A BIG
CITY THEY COME IN AND IT
COLLAPSES.
THE SMALLER TOWNS ARE BEING
OVERWHELMS EVERY DAY.
BRIAN: THINK OF THE BIG STATES
THAT HAVE TO WRITE CHECKS.
AND THE OPERATION IN ARIZONA.
IN NEW YORK THE MAYOR IS ASKING
FOR A BILLION DOLLARS.
THIS IS MONEY PAID BY TAX
DOLLARS FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
HERE ARE SOME DEMOCRATS WEIGHING
IN.
TELL ME IF YOU HAVE A REASON FOR
HOPE HERE.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHY THEY KEEP
AVOIDING THE BORDER AND SAYING
THERE ARE OTHER THINGS MORE
IMPORTANT THAN THE BORDER.
IF THERE IS A CRISIS, SHOW UP.
JUST SHOW UP.
>> WE SENT A LETTER SIMILAR
THREE WEEKS AGO THAT SAID WRITES
YOUR PLAN.
WE NEVER GOT A RESPONSE.
IF THEY DON'T HAVE A PLAN, THEN
THEY NEED TO WAIT TO END.
>> WE ALL KNOW IT'S A CRISIS.
WHEN YOU HAVE A CRISIS IN YOUR
COUNTRY YOU SHOULD DEAL WITH IT.
BRIAN: THREE DEMOCRATS ADMITTING
WHAT WE ALL KNOW.
IS THERE HOPE THERE?
>> THE REPUBLICAN HOUSE WILL BE
ABLE TO WORK WITH PEOPLE LIKE
HENRY CUELLAR.
JON TESTER JUMPED ON TOP OF
THIS.
HE'S NOT ON THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
REPUBLICAN DEMOCRAT OR
INDEPENDENTS, THEY THINK IT'S A
CRISIS AND THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHY THE ADMINISTRATION IS SO
PASSIVE AND OUT OF TOUCH.
WHEN THE HOMELAND SECURITY
SECRETARY SAYS THE BORDER IS
SECURE, AND YOU ARE SEEING THESE
PICTURES ON THE EVENING NEWS,